China may
be one step closer
to attacking Taiwan,
staging
massive military exercises
miles off the Taiwanese coast.
Senior defense officials in Taipei say
12 Chinese warships
surrounded the island,
simulating a sea and air blockade
for the second time in eight months.
Taiwan's military says
three days
of war games
reveal rapid progress
by the Chinese Navy,
what appear
to be
the first ever
simulations of aircraft carrier strikes
with a highly advanced
J 15 fighter fleet.
China calls the flying
shark on the Taiwan Strait.
China's Shandong
aircraft carrier
launched 80
fighter jet missions
and 40 helicopter flights.
The drills came with an ominous warning.
China's military is ready to fight
the Taiwanese
military issuing
a strong condemnation,
saying it does not seek to escalate
but is determined to safeguard
its sovereignty.
Is Beijing, in your view,
threatening Taiwan with war?
Yes, indeed.
Taiwan's foreign minister, Joseph
Wu, speaking
exclusively to CNN,
condemning China's military moves,
menacing imagery shows
a barrage of ballistic
missiles aimed at the island.
China launched real missiles
over Taiwan for the first time last year.
Look at military sites
exercises and also the rhetoric.
They seem to be trying to get ready
to launch a war against Taiwan.
China calls the drills
a serious warning
against the Taiwan
separatist forces, collusion
with external forces
and a necessary
move to defend national sovereignty
and territorial integrity.
Chinese exercises,
like similar drills last August followed
high profile meetings with U.S.
House speakers
Nancy Pelosi in Taiwan,
Kevin McCarthy in California.
Meetings the foreign minister
calls crucial
to counter decades
of diplomatic isolation by Beijing.
China cannot dictate
how Taiwan make friends
in China cannot dictate how our friends
want to show support to Taiwan.
Support includes
nine rounds of weapons
sales to the island.
Under the Biden administration alone.
U.S.
intelligence believes the People's
Liberation Army
is acting on orders from President
Xi Jinping himself.
The PLA told to be ready by 2027
to take Taiwan by force one U.S.
general claiming
it could happen even sooner
in 2020 52 years from now
a war
that could involve the US and its allies
as this fragile island
democracy fights to fend off
a future Chinese attack.
And next time it may not be a drill
but there are concerns tonight
that global democracies
may not be united,
particularly after these comments
from the French
President, Emmanuel Macron,
on the heels of his state visit
to Beijing.
He almost was echoing the Chinese
President Xi Jinping's talking points.
He was
cautioning Europe against
being drawn into a Taiwan crisis,
saying that Europe should resist pressure
to be a follower of America.
Well, here in Taipei, of course,
lawmakers are asking
why would an advanced
democratic country
ignore the lives
and potential deaths of people
in other countries?
They really say that those comments
are puzzling Erica.